I don't see us staying four days a week  in the future I I could see in the  future going down to two  um and maybe increasing the number of  Street interviews or something else  um it's not to say that I won't ever go  up to four but  um just the last year the show has  started at nine and it's just so late  that I kind of want to see if we can  start it earlier and I really want to  just like get a normal sleep schedule  again  um so it's either I'm gonna do it less  days of the week so it's only one to two  days I'm staying up crazy late or  um I'm gonna move the show earlier  [Music]  um  so I don't know what I'm gonna do yet um  I'd like to film more wife school I  might take January off I'm sorry I'm  getting  um I might take January off from shows  um and just do just do like interviews